Багато українців досі вагаються, робити їм щеплення від коронавірусу чи ні.
Дехто не вірить, що щеплення їх дійсно може захистити.
Дехто боїться вакцини більше, ніж самої хвороби.
Інші просто легковажать ризиками, сподіваючись, що перечекає нову хвилю і якось пронесе.
Не знаю, діти мої не хочуть. Казали, що не будуть. Не знаю, що це воно за вакцинація…
Якщо мене насильно не змусять, то я не буду вакцинуватися.
Я не вірю, що допомагає ця вакцина. У мене подруга мого віку вакцинувалася.
Ну, мене, може, поки ще не придавило.
А якщо пізно буде? Значить доля така…
DW почитала дослідження, поспілкувалася з експертами і зібрала 5 головних переваг,
чому вакцинуватися все ж варто.
Жодна вакцина не захищає на 100%. Однак усі поважні міжнародні дослідження
засвідчили високу ефективність вакцин від COVID-19.
Наприклад, з Pfizer шанси не підхопити первинний штам "альфа" - майже 94%.
А захист проти штаму "дельта", який нині, власне, лютує в Україні, -  88%.
Moderna має ефективність у 90%, а проти агресивнішої "дельти" - 72.
Ефективність вакцини AstraZeneca дещо нижча - 80% і 69% відповідно.
Ще одна наявна в Україні вакцина Сoronavac/Sinovac дає захист на 66%,
щоб не підхопити первинний вірус і 59% відсотків проти "дельти".
Однак увага: слід пам'ятати, що з часом, дієвість вакцин втрачається.
У середньому через рік їх необхідно повторити.
Навіть якщо вакцинована людина захворіє на "ковід", завдяки щепленню
перебіг хвороби відбуватиметься радше в легкій формі.
Випробування показали, що вакцини Moderna і Pfizer знижують ризик розвитку
важких симптомів "ковіду" на понад 90%.
AstraZeneca має трохи меншу ефективність - 70%.
Тобто симптоми у вакцинованої людини при коронавірусі слабші, ніж у нещепленої.
Вакцина запобігає важкому перебігу хвороби, коли необхідна госпіталізація
і підключення до апаратів штучного дихання.
За даними Центру з контролю та профілактики захворювань США,
93% вакцинованих людей, які згодом все ж захворіли на коронавірус,
були убезпечені від госпіталізації. Крім того, вакциновані люди, які все ж захворіли на коронавірус,
мають значно кращі шанси уникнути довгострокових наслідків "ковіду",
які можуть бути не менш неприємними, ніж сама хвороба.
Велике дослідження Оксфордського університету засвідчило:
вакцини справді знижують шанси передати хворобу іншим. Дослідники проаналізували
контакти 100 000 інфікованих людей. Результати щодо Pfizer, до прикладу,
показали, що вакцина убезпечує 65% хворих на коронавірус від передачі інфекції оточуючим.
Це означає, що загалом менше людей будуть інфіковані коронавірусом.
Але насамперед це убезпечує від зараження COVID-19 людей з груп ризику -
хронічно хворих та людей похилого віку, для яких хвороба чи ускладнення від неї
можуть стати смертельними.
Розповсюджена в Україні думка, що, перехворівши на коронавірус,
людина вже захищена антитілами, а отже, вакцинуватися немає сенсу.
Однак дослідження показують, що у людини, яка перехворіла на "ковід",
а потім не вакцинувалася, ризик інфікуватися повторно вдвічі вищий, ніж у тих,
хто перехворів і згодом зробив щеплення. Щоправда, рекомендації,
наскільки швидко варто вакцинуватися після одужання, різняться.
Тому краще порадитися зі своїм лікарем.
Сертифікат вакцинації відчиняє багато дверей, зокрема, у транспорт, заклади харчування
і розважальні локації. Чим більше людей зроблять щеплення,
тим менше громадське життя буде вразливим до коронавірусу.
Це послабить тиск на медичну систему. Дозволить швидше вийти з карантину
і скасувати пандемічні обмеження. Люди у групах ризику зможуть знову
зажити повноцінним життям. А економіка почне відновлюватися -
знімуть обмеження зі сфери послуг, відновиться туристична інфраструктура.
За планами ВООЗ, 70% населення кожної країни мають вакцинуватися,
щоб утворився колективний імунітет.
А отже, щоб ми змогли повернутися до нормального життя.